en este vídeo vamos a hablar un poquito
más acerca de los circuitos con resistor
es en paralelo recordemos rápidamente
los resistor es están en paralelo si
comparten dos nodos y bueno si comparten
dos nodos entonces tienen el mismo
voltaje tenemos el voltaje por aquí a
este resistor le vamos a llamar r uno a
este ere dos ahora ya hemos encontrado
una forma de sustituir a los receptores
en paralelo por un solo resistor al cual
le llamamos r paralelo y encontramos que
uno entre r paralelo es igual a uno
entre r uno más uno entre r 2 y lo que
vamos a hacer en este vídeo es trabajar
con esta expresión vamos a escribirla en
otra forma que puede ser más fácil de
recordar y utilizar y nos puede decir
algunas cosas acerca de los resistor es
en paralelo y bueno también vamos a
hacer un ejemplo en el que r
y r-2 tienen exactamente la misma
resistencia y vamos a ver qué sucede en
ese caso pero por el momento simplemente
vamos a hacer un poco de manipulaciones
algebraicas sobre esta expresión así es
que vamos a empezar por reescribir esto
por aquí 1 / erp es igual a 1 entre r
1 / r 2 y lo que vamos a hacer es
encontrar una expresión donde ya no
tengamos este 1 / rp sino que tengamos
directamente que rp es igual a alguna
otra expresión y por aquí queremos tener
un solo término en lugar de tener dos
fracciones que son dos términos así es
que vamos a empezar por aquí para sumar
estas dos fracciones necesitamos un
común denominador y el más sencillo como
un denominador es r 1 por r 2 entonces 1
entre r paralelo es igual y aquí tomamos
1 entre r 1 y multiplicamos el numerador
y el denominador por r 2 y luego sumamos
1 entre r 2 1 entre r 2 por r 1 entre r
1 y al hacer estas multiplicaciones nos
queda que 1 entre r paralelo es igual
r 2 r2 / r 1 x r 2 r
por r 2 que es el común denominador y
luego sumamos r 1 r 1 entre el común
denominador r 1 x r 2 r 1 x r 2 y
entonces ahora sí ya puedo sumar estas
dos fracciones y nos queda por aquí que
1 entre r paralelo es igual a r 1 r uno
más
r 2 r2 estamos siguiendo el orden
numérico entre el común denominador r 1
por r 2 si es que de este lado ya
tenemos un solo término vamos bien pero
de este lado queremos aerp por lo que
vamos a tomar los recíprocos y entonces
erp es igual
r1 r2 es uno por r 2 / r1 r2 r
más r 2 lo único que hicimos fue voltear
esta expresión y esta también es una
expresión muy fácil de recordar y con
ella podemos combinar resistor es en
paralelo la resistencia equivalente a 2
resistor es en paralelo es la
multiplicación de sus resistencias entre
la suma de sus resistencias así es que
en el numerador tenemos los productos y
en el denominador tenemos las sumas y
eso también es súper fácil de recordar y
bueno estas dos expresiones son
equivalentes
así es que nada más tienes que observar
de cual te acuerdas más fácilmente y
bueno también cuál es más fácil de
calcular bueno y ahora vamos a ver un
ejercicio utilizando esta fórmula
digamos que tenemos dos resistor es en
paralelo los cuales se ven más o menos
así
digamos que este resistor tiene una
resistencia de 1000 oms mientras que
este otro resistor tiene una resistencia
de 4000 oms y la pregunta es cuál es la
resistencia equivalente a estos dos
resistor es en paralelo cuál es la
resistencia de un resistor que sustituye
a estos dos resistor es en paralelo de
tal forma que la corriente sea la misma
si tuviéramos el mismo voltaje y bueno
como te puedes imaginar lo único que
necesitamos es utilizar esta expresión
que tenemos aquí la resistencia en
paralelo de estos dos resistor es es
igual a mil ohms del primer resistor
4000 oms del segundo resistor entre la
suma de esos dos o sea mil más cuatro
mil y eso pues bueno es cuatro y seis
ceros
entre 5000 y le quitamos tres ceros al
denominador y el numerador y nos queda
4000 entre 5 lo cual son 800 800 oms así
es que el resistor equivalente a esos
dos resistor es en paralelo rp tiene una
resistencia de 800 oms ok
así es como se utiliza esta expresión
ahora algo súper importante que podemos
notar aquí la resistencia equivalente en
paralelo siempre es más chica que la más
chica de las resistencias en paralelo
originales aquí la más pequeña es 1000 y
la resistencia en paralelo es 800 más
pequeña que ésta y bueno esa es una
propiedad de las resistencias en
paralelo porque la corriente tiene dos
caminos sobre los cuales puede fluir la
resistencia efectiva siempre va a ser
más pequeña que cualquiera de las
resistencias en paralelo
eso es porque siempre hay otro camino
por el cual puede fluir la corriente en
fin esta de aquí es la expresión para
dos resistor es en paralelo y es una
expresión muy sencilla muy fácil de
recordar
así es que podemos irnos más abajo y no
estarlo viendo vamos a ver un caso muy
especial vamos a ver qué pasa si r 1 es
igual a 2 en este caso cuánto vale erp
que queremos averiguar cuánto vale r en
paralelo y bueno para este caso de todas
formas estamos exactamente la misma
expresión la cual nos dice que rp es
igual a r 1 por r 2 pero como tienen el
mismo valor simplemente voy a poner una
r o sea que aquí tenemos
por r / r1 r2 pero simplemente vamos a
poner r más r y aquí se están
multiplicando bueno esto se simplifica
como r al cuadrado r al cuadrado entre r
r2 r y bueno esto se puede simplificar
todavía más podemos eliminar esta r con
una de estas dos erres y entonces nos
queda simplemente r sobre 2 si r 1 es
igual a r2 entonces
rp es igual a r entre 2 donde la r
obviamente es igual a r1 y r2 y bueno
esto claro que también tiene sentido si
tenemos por aquí dos resistor es en
paralelo y decimos que este resistor
tiene una resistencia de 300
y bueno estamos diciendo que r 1 es
igual a r 2 así es que este resistor
también tiene una resistencia de 300 oms
esto nos dice que la resistencia
equivalente es de 150 oms y en este
circuito hay una asimetría bastante
bonita como estos receptores están en
paralelo tienen el mismo voltaje y aquí
en este circuito en particular tienen la
misma resistencia entonces la corriente
que fluya también va a ser la misma pero
aquí la corriente se divide en dos
caminos así es que por estos dos
resistor es que está fluyendo la mitad
de la corriente y por eso es que la
resistencia en paralelo tiene que ser
del doble del tamaño que la resistencia
efectiva porque tienen exactamente el
mismo voltaje pero en estos resistor es
fluye la mitad de la corriente que en un
circuito donde hay un solo resistor y
por eso es que aquí tenemos que dividir
entre dos porque por este resistor está
fluyendo el doble de corriente que por
cualquiera de estos dos
ya tenemos aquí esta fórmula que nos
dice que si la resistencia son iguales
entonces la resistencia en paralelo la
resistencia equivalente es igual a esa
resistencia pero dividida entre 2